what is happening reject nation I'm Greg
Alva and I'm John I'm Andrew Andrew
Terpening it's here with us today he is
one of our fellow patron members and
he's from Texas so he's visiting
California so I said dude you should
just come on the channel since they're
only out here for a week here he is
today men have a lot of the Google
hangout there's not a total stranger to
us that would be kinda weird he's a lot
creepier real life and we found him
outside that yeah we all died another up
in the video if you want
I've even enjoying your time on patreon
Andrea that's pretty fun actually you
get a good connection with you sweet
alright you can go home now but I want
you for the patron I feel apart of a
jurors Awards here is also whatever
video if you requests we will definitely
check out what we are Andrews slit we
artist slave that's what money can buy
you and one of the things you request it
was horror movie day care so I thought
and your since you're here just give you
a library you're going to have to watch
the video I can just hear back and look
without ever had a better reaction and
this is a react office it's a real
competition I've invented here I'm
judging something finally to call a
humor these guys are hilarious yeah I
love them haven't seen this one I went
to college and I have a sense of humor
so this is right up my alley a loser I'm
going to hit play
[Music]
hi I'm Katherine baby I'm the director
and happy dreams day care we offer a
welcoming environment for all children
regardless of any personal or
supernatural issues they may have it
move don't use urge life flow or
possessed or Antichrist
Buffy dream stick here is an opportunity
to speak and easy
[Music]
well just Tony want to do sucks don't
you Oh
we try to engage kids in fun we also
make sure kids get plenty of outdoor
time I've always loved living with kids
before this I was a nurse in a goose
mental hospital after that burned down I
was a governess criminal bathroom along
come on oh not right now I have you okay
okay does anyone have a book they'd like
us to read it some parents come to me at
the wrist and and I completely
understand there's nothing scarier than
parenthood I was a little concerned with
something that manager today I couldn't
find it yes each day come next we are I
was wondering why she show up TV time is
over the evil knife some kids are a real
handful
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody if you liked that video
just click right on to subscribe I'm
already so subscribe so good so good be
still good game to sleep wow it's a
great climate editor Wow yeah a good a
good job man
that was [ __ ] awesome that's
hilarious all those sketches like that
make fun of so for like they bring you
in like different things of this it's
like the child horror cinematic universe
you're taking things that in context or
spooky but then adding them to regular
let light I love that whole thing where
he's on the swing and then she's like
it's two times like oh yeah yeah never
mind about that happiness daddy doesn't
want to drink at Aliso in there you have
people to Tony alright
yeah and also him being shy to interact
with the other shiny bill that was
really clever actually a as a person
who's seen pretty much all these movies
that they're scooping right here that
was just excited to see them all I
couldn't same streaming editors double
yellow fondant adorable about watching
all that and it's cleverly done the day
care I even like the made-up character
of the lady in charge of the day oh yeah
yeah
ordered a youth mental hospital is and
then you know before it burned down yeah
I've got this little casual about it
like this is her world that she's in I
like when people treat horror universes
just like that's life you know yeah
nothing get routine that urges
outlandish and terrible oh you're this
gets come out 23:13 is there a man they
could do it or even when there are the
kids are waiting to Evil Dead book yeah
really baby yeah I start chanting it
yeah too bad I couldn't afford to get
smart to come out of the TV if that
would have been that would have been
totally creative they blew their budge
on the head spinning a very nice shot
that hit the meeting also like sharp
color Corrections called tumors been
around since like the beginning of you
yeah I mean really the first video I saw
people is that Batman skit tell Batman
in shooting his voice do you I never
yeah well I had the drugs and thought of
face well Andrew thank you for
requesting that my beautiful tall friend
you can't tell right now but I'm not
sure really talk we raised our chairs
actually see all the way up and I'm
blaming exact word [ __ ]
how does it feel right
darn engine I'm taller than you well you
guys can subscribe you the real rejects
click that notification bill is that
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
this guy is a Turk Smith on Instagram
link in the description box go check out
our patreon it's whatever
happy one day a happy one it's alright
see ya